buck est-ce que tu te souviens de moi le nom de ta mère
est Sarah il avait l'habitude de porter des journaux dans
tes chaussures tu es un homme recherché
Capitaine vivant, beaucoup de gens vous voient
comme un héros, il y en a qui préféreraient
le mot justicier que vous avez opéré avec
un pouvoir illimité et sans supervision,
c'est quelque chose que le monde ne peut plus
tolérer
Je sais à quel point Bucky est-ce que vous restez à l'écart
celui-ci s'il vous plaît vous ne faites qu'empirer les choses
vous dites que vous allez m'arrêter
il y aura des conséquences capitaine vous
semblez un peu sur la défensive ce qui a été une
longue journée je pense que j'accepte les limites
nous ne sommes pas meilleurs que les méchants ce n'est pas
le dernier
parfois je veux  pour te frapper dans tes
dents parfaites,
je veux juste m'assurer que nous considérons toutes
nos options juste les gens qui te tirent dessus
finissent généralement par me tirer dessus aussi
tu sais ce qui va se
passer tu veux vraiment te sortir
de ça
que faire  Nous faisons  nous nous battons
désolé Tony tu sais que je ne ferais pas ce
combat autrement mais c'est mon
ami donc je l'étais
toi